I want to talk about something we've
learned about the Donald Trump campaign
campaigns are a really good indication
of how a candidate would be as president
of the United States we know Donald
Trump's campaign has been a total mess
and we we've seen spokespeople and
staffers and surrogates regularly
surprised by Donald Trump's statements
and decisions unable to comment on them
in any reasonable way we've seen
contradictions between Donald Trump and
surrogates in media often within hours
of each other
constant shakeups his campaign
management has changed multiple times
and now we've learned that many Trump
staffers have just walked off the job
because Donald Trump refused to pay them
the Washington Post reported a few days
ago that Donald Trump's policy shop this
is a group of staffers that worked out
of an office in Alexandria Virginia
it's basically defunct because they were
not getting paid they were working very
very long hours they were the ones
writing the policy memos and the
briefings which by the way don't seem to
ever have gotten much attention from
Donald Trump because he would just show
up and read polls at most of his events
they were putting in very long hours
they were very involved in planning the
Republican National Convention they
wanted to make the campaign look like an
actual actual professional operation but
last month after the convention many of
the staffers started dropping like flies
because they were not getting paid now
of course like all Trump staffers they
had to sign these non-disclosure
agreements but Donald Trump did not pay
them we have now learned the Huffington
Post is reported that Trump hasn't paid
some of his top staffers either in
addition to these I guess I call them
the policy wonks who were writing policy
stuff for Trump and if you have read any
newspapers recently you know that Donald
Trump has a long track record of not
paying many of the people who work for
him this includes contractors this
includes all sorts of different people
he's been screwing people over for
decades if I were working for Donald
Trump not that I would but I would
definitely try to get my money upfront
and what what's amazing to me about this
rachel is that we are seeing the exact
same pattern the Trump business entity
the Trump campaign entity so many of the
same patterns why does anyone think it
would all of a sudden be different if
Donald Trump was president I honestly
don't know because if you're thinking
about all of these people who he
employed and didn't pay and some of them
who are walking off the job
what if he's I know I'm sorry I've now
mentioned this twice saying what if he's
in the White House but what if he is in
the White House and then he has employed
someone that he hasn't paid and they
walk off the job and they were supposed
to give a large address that day I don't
think that kind of type that type of
thing can't be happening although I
would like to think there are systems in
place in the White House that everyone
would still get paid yeah but it still
worries me because if someone is using
deceptive tactics to study for a test
they're cheating off their classmates
there they're pulling reports from from
hidden files who's to say that on the
day of the test they wouldn't cheat
who's to say that if you ever employ
that person they're not going to be
doing all sorts of sketchy sketchy jobs
sketchy things in their jobs later I
think you're right that if someone is a
direct administration official they're
going to get paid because it's the
government who is who is running that uh
but who knows what else Trump would be
doing and the fact that we're hearing
the exact same story from campaign
staffers and from contractors about just
flat-out not paying his bills not paying
people this is incredibly disturbing and
I know that the Trump supporters don't
care they're there I guess part of those
deplorable --zz you couldn't say
anything to them and as Trump said Trump
could start shooting people on Fifth
Avenue and those individuals would still
support him but this is really really
vile and low and again it's not
drastically different allegations it's
the exact same stories we're hearing
from everybody